a new book argues you can be more
successful in life if you learn
different things and don't try to be an
expert it's called range wide generalist
triumph in a specialized world author
David Epstein says diverse experiences
are helpful in science music parenting
and even sports one example Roger
Federer he decided to focus on tennis
after growing up playing several sports
David Epstein is with us David good
morning welcome thank you for having me
this is something I spent years covering
businesses and this is something
actually a lot of CEOs said to me that
they were always looking for people who
were actually nimble not necessarily
laser focused that's right and in fact
CEOs themselves so LinkedIn just did
research on a half million members and
found that one of the best predictors of
who would become an executive was the
number of different job functions they
had worked across within an industry
which kind of goes against everything
we're told about just pick and stick
yeah yeah I was fascinated by what you
said about the 10,000 hours because I so
believed the 10,000 hours if you do
10,000 hours you will become proficient
at it you sort of knocked that down and
then you even got Malcolm Gladwell who
first told us about 10,000 hours to say
yeah maybe you're right yeah well what
are you thinking there he says so he
said I changed his mind some not not to
mean that practice isn't incredibly
important yes but if you look for
example at sports and music the domains
that we most associate with early
specialization when scientists study
future elites in those domains what they
see is that they actually have what they
call a sampling period early on they do
a variety of sports variety of
instruments gain a breadth of general
skills learn about their interests and
their abilities before they focus and
systematically delay specializing until
later than peers who plateau at low
early and this doesn't only apply to
elite athletes or aspiring athletes I
mean this is actually a quietly
inspiring book because so many of us
these days we have we live chaotic
professional lives you start in one
thing the industry changes you have to
do another thing and you feel like
that's a liability but in fact as your
book makes the point it's actually a
unique advantage wait I like how Tony
described your book quietly inspiring
but I think it's gonna be a business
book you know yeah but you're running
through an airport or whatever no and
and I hope it's something you're like
you know what I feel better about me I
the guy that was in print for a long
time we beat ourselves up about trying
different things yeah right and you know
like Mark Zuckerberg famously at 22 said
young people are just smarter right but
brand-new research shows that founders
of blockbuster startups on the day of
founding have an average age of 46 they
usually have to zigzag yeah so we should
drop our obsession with precocity yeah
it is exacting yeah you said it's not
really a sign of weakness or scattered
brain it just means that you're really
that when you start to focus it really
does make a difference yeah do you have
it I love the point you made about
cardiologists you said the best time to
because cardio the best time to get a
heart procedure is when all the
cardiologists write a National
Conference which surprised me why not
all of them but the most special
specialize if you're checked into a
hospital when there's a national
cardiology conference and this
specialist cardiologists are away it
turns out that they're so attached to
certain types of specialized procedures
if they use them over and over even when
they're not indicated and so the the
rates of complications and death
actually go up so this incredible study
showed that you're actually safer going
when when they're away so it's a problem
to have people be that specialized where
when all they have is a certain
procedure every problem looks like that
kind of nail yeah what's your advice to
parents who we're all worried about you
knew you're a new father you want to
protect your kids for that for what what
comes right Tony yeah Tony's a new
father to your baby how old is Andre
four months how old is Teddy he is six
weeks what did I make up for both of us
so what do we as parents what do you do
what is it the the the lesson from your
book to help your kids be the best they
can be the only way they can learn what
they're good at and interested in is by
trying stuff and the best thing you can
do is expose them to a lot of things
help them reflect on those things that's
called self-regulatory learning where
not only do you expose them to things
but then help them reflect on were they
good at that were they interested in it
and and the only way you can figure out
what you can do is by trying things and
do not worry about missing the next
Mozart or Tiger Woods the way we tell
those stories is not right in both cases
those fathers were reacting to the
child's display of interest and prowess
earlier not the reverse the other way
they're not parent created as Tiger said
his father never
him to play golf ever as he said if the
child's interest that matters not the
parents interest in having a child play
so you should not at all worried that
you're gonna miss that opportunity
because if it's there it will show
itself and outside of that the best
thing to do is expose broadly and help
them reflect on those experience I love
that we can all take a breath we can
maybe get some sleep and the line I
found in Gail's copy the book is the
message to people is don't feel behind
you're making a change
you actually have an advantage yeah this
is people get more and more specialized
and especially see a smaller portion of
all these complex systems in the world
having these diverse experiences it's
it's not falling behind it's investing
in yourself and in breath and that
becomes a source of power later on David
Epstein I feel much better I haven't
talked to you thank you thank you very
much